we've been looking so far at line and
the equations that represent those lines
right we get if you want to represent a
point what do you use you use
coordinates right but if you want a
whole bunch of points and they all fit
together in some kind of logical way
like all being on your why you don't use
I wanted to use an equation something
equals something
okay now I've interested in trying to
work out what if we know some
characteristics about the line like say
in gradients at a place it goes through
can we work out its equation if we know
that information so I want to first just
by getting a picture what would this
look like okay just monthly in our heads
so that when we get to an equation at
the end we can check it is some
reasonable or not so would you please
underneath for your prettiest drop me
upper set of axes as you draw it don't
you Straub are anywhere like equally
spaced out think about this point here
that is going to have to go onto your
Cartesian plane and then think about
what it means when a white has gradient
to what direction is going is how you
would describe it and therefore how much
of the graphic you should draw okay so
this is what my set of axes is roughly
going to look like
that's really what travel
okay and you can see I do have all four
of my quadrants here but one two are
much bigger than three and four
can anyone suggest by looking at the
information provided why might that be a
good direction to headed yeah yeah
fantastic
I'm going to start over here and then
I'm going to go up really fast okay I
mean there is going to be a purple light
if I'm not going to draw most of it so
that's why I have most of my stuff above
here you know it has to have that much
but it'll probably be easier to see the
graph if that's what you look like so
now I'm going to put a point negative 3
comma 1 onto my Cartesian plane put it
somewhere like over here and boy go up
one unit that will give me the
coordinates I'm ok so place the big fat
negative three color one and now I want
to draw up my line with a Grady of two
now you can actually do this like
because you guys have good flavor on you
you can actually do this quite
accurately the gradient 2 is the same as
a grating of 2 over 1 so River gradient
diffraction something over something
whatever 1 rise over run that means
every time you run across one unit you
will rise to you does that makes it and
that's what gives it its steepness okay
so in fact what your green paper you can
do something like this you go across one
here's my 1 and then you're going to
rise to I just had some magic so don't
agree obviously okay we're going 1 and
then 2 1 and 2 and if you have a look at
what you created here to sort of step
out our picture then you can join up the
dots and that shows you what you should
be expecting for your mind ok
so now we have a picture in our minds on
a page for what we ought to get this is
not an equation though so how will we
work it out so far you guys go to forms
for equation that gives you straight
right do you remember what the two fours
are any takers okay general form we know
general form I'm just going to write up
the top you because you don't wasn't
ever able to look at this general form
the actual equation is that to the K
what comes up to that X plus c1 3 y plus
C equals your gray and by the way just
while we're talking about general form a
B and C what kinds of numbers of those
again we want them to be integers and we
particularly want a to be a positive
integer okay so cool we remember that it
was another form what was it looking
simpler okay slope-intercept form
that started with a why what was on the
right hand side MX plus B this is what
the gradient but here this is the
intercept which one is gonna give like
if the wave is that very good now I can
now choose I've got two to choose from
which should I use or which might be
more helpful to me as a starting point
to use this information now have a look
at the two pieces of Donovan and it
supplied to you what are they great here
and a coordinate great so when you hear
the word gradient which of these two is
going to be more useful to you clearly
the second one because it's got the
gradient right there so what I'm going
to do is I'm going to say he is going to
be my starting point and I'm going to
say well if I'm doing the great into
this then then I can write the equation
of the line the equation of the line
we'll be I can substitute integration
and told to me y equals 2x now do I know
what this B is y-intercept who at the
moment at the rivet I don't know what is
I will work out what is going until I've
done that I'm just going to write plus B
it's a pruning rule I still don't know
what its values that's fine okay now
here's an important piece of logic
I've used this gradient good that's good
but I also need to bring this kind of
play it's not just any line really radio
- it's a particularly okay so underneath
here where I've written like a 2x plus B
I'm going to say since the line passes
through these coordinates here negative
3 comma 1 about to finish your sentence
but before I do I want you to help you
remember if 3 and 1 are coordinates
which one is which the e 3 is the and an
x coordinate that's worth writing down
and what is that cool now what that
means is X is equal to negative 3 at the
time when y is equal to 1 so therefore I
ought to be able to put those x and y
numbers into here and it should work
right so here they are going to finish
the sentence since my passes through
their common x equals negative 3 and y
equals 1 is a solution to this equation
or solves the equation or in other words
say it satisfies the equation they all
be the same thing ok lady 3 comma 1
that's an x and a y value so those x and
y values should make this equation work
so I'm going to substitute them in and
see what happens
have a look I'm going to go from here
now but instead of Y and X I'm going to
substitute in these numbers that have
been supplied by the Corps
I'm looking to write why I have to front
I'm going to write one
that's the y-coordinate isn't all right
too but I'm not going to write X I'm
going to write they give three that's
the x-coordinate I'll speed I still
don't know what that is I'm about to
find out
can you help me simplify this a little
bit you can click I want to make beta
subject right so what shall I do to both
sides
watch out it is a negative here set it
over come back to counter I will add 6
to both sides so this is a one room
actually one I'll put B on the left hand
side because we usually say that when
it's a subject okay so equals seven
what's being again like what
significance like if the wine is it does
that look like look at your diagram that
you drew does it look like seven it
should could you then well you can
actually see the way I've drawn it you
can see remember when I went across one
up two across one up to have a look out
fire I went up to another to another - I
went six up what was the y-value one
side of that one so when you go six up
you get seven so this is really
important that the visual picture sort
of confirms to you that my algebra
worked out so now I can say what the
equation of the line is therefore Y is
equal to two and pass and thought okay
I've answered the question that's great
however it was a little bit awkward like
we had to sort of go through lots of
twists and turns
see this guy here y equals MX plus B it
was really nice for grading Granger's
kind of plot straight in there where you
have to do any work we just wrote it
down but then to get all this like we
had to think really hard because we
didn't have the y-intercept we had some
other stuff but we didn't have exactly
what that full of the equation wanted so
instead of this instead of just gradient
intercept form we're going to develop
quite gradient for
different form same kind of loan but if
you have a point instead of an intercept
you can do what you need you just drop
it straight no a great long amount of
working required